après des demandes répétées durant des
décennies seront repris la découverte de
restes humains sur les terrains
d'anciens pensionnat pour que le pape
décide de venir s'excuser auprès des
nations autochtones quelques semaines
après avoir reçu la visite d'une
délégation de chefs de plusieurs nations
au vatican l'itinéraire du souverain
pontife semble se préciser sa sainteté
doit déjà se rendre au congo et au
soudan juillet il pourrait ensuite
visiter québec iq alouettes et edmonton
il souhaitait si les choses ça donne de
venir autour de la fête de sainte-anne
associé au sud sud halte à la fête de
sainte anne c'est le 26 juillet alors
viendront-ils pour la fête un peu avant
la fête un peu après la fête mais ça
nous donne déjà une idée d'autant plus
que la fête de la sainte-anne est
importante et hautement symbolique pour
bien des nations autochtones la dernière
visite d'un pape dans la région de
québec remonte à
1984 alors que jean paul 2 s'était
notamment rendu à la basilique sainte
anne le pape françois d'ailleurs est
déjà venu à québec en 2008 dans le cadre
d'un congrès eucharistique alors qu'il
était encore cardinal
mais à ce stade préliminaire du périple
aucune mention des sites d' ancien
pensionnat de kamloops en
colombie-britannique et de marival en
saskatchewan où des centaines de tombes
anonymes ont été retrouvés il doit y
aller et il vaut sûrement de faire donc
il s'agit de voir au niveau du voyage
qu'est ce qui va être le plus j'allais
dire face et la sphère contenu des
déplacements opportun bien que plusieurs
évêques canadiens soient d'accord avec
cette idée ces derniers répète néanmoins
que malgré la volonté du pape rien n'est
certain quant à son voyage sa sainteté a
85 ans et la pandémie n'est pas terminée
de quoi agacer ceux qui ont vécu dans
les pensionnats et qui attendent des
excuses depuis des décennies les gens
sont en train de mourir les gens sont en
train de nous quitter la plupart des
générations qui ont été affectés par ça
alors je comprends le le contexte de
vide de pandémie mais à mon avis
l'incertitude on y pics atteints avec
cela si la visite du pape se concrétise
celle ci pourrait être forte en émotions
pour bien des survivants des pensionnats
reste maintenant à voir dans quelle
région l'église voudra se faire
pardonner ici qu'on ne comptait pas là
radio-canada à sainte anne de beaupré